schönefeld Airport in Berlin a group of
young Germans are flying out to Israel
for an exchange expectations are high
for the trip I'm interested in for
contrasts in Israeli society and the
effect that has on politics 180
youngsters are taking part in the
exchange program when i'ma chona is one
of them like everyone else in the group
Adobe his first time in Israel for young
law student is looking forward to
getting to know her country the magnet
what made you Rosalind haughey first
stop Jerusalem and the Wailing Wall at
the foot of a temple mount
that's mr. young I'm asking myself why
humanity has it been able to figure out
how to peacefully share this holy site
mr. Taylor yad vashem is Israel was
official memorial to the victims of the
Holocaust here gwynnie I gets to see one
of the worst atrocities in human history
from a different perspective
the Earth's torture because we're German
we have learned a lot about the history
of Israel and the Jewish people in
Germany but it was something else to
really experience it up close from
Israeli here in Israel in Jerusalem a
group also got to experience a different
side to Israel itself the Mediterranean
metropolis of Tel Aviv is laid-back
Liberal and creative the hosts bought
the first round of beer on velocity
arrest Ava group met Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu the israeli premier
welcome for young people to his country
and emphasized how much he and his
family like Germany I like brilliant I
visit billion my children visit
brilliant and I'm glad that young
Berliners again Germans are visiting
Israel welcome to all of it Netanyahu
then spoke about the Middle East
conflict making sure his guests
understood his government's stance the
policy measures like there weren't any
Palestinians there of course you can't
really expect that now I understand
Israel's perspective better than ever
before that was probably the point of
this trip or at least an aspect of it I
not break tough on these future German
leaders will take with them a unique
perspective on Israeli society its
problems and its cultural riches